there's something about defining your
positioning there's something about
understanding and defining your
audience's problems and desires
and then there's something about
committing to post at least one
significant post
let me ask you this question is growing
on youtube
hard do you feel stuck and overwhelmed
when it comes to figuring out how to
connect the dots on not just getting
views
but making money off of your youtube
channel i've talked to so many content
creators to that get to this point
where they're making videos consistently
but they can't figure out how to
marry the monetization with their
youtube channel
and in today's episode we're gonna be
diving into part
two of our four steps to building a six
to seven figure
youtube channel my name is heather
torres and i'm the host of the think
media podcast the number one podcast to
help you grow your influence on youtube
and then turn that influence into a high
impact and a high profit
youtube channel now this is part two of
this series so if you didn't get last
week's episode i highly recommend going
back and listening to that one
first it's gonna be the foundation and
it really lays that framework for you
as we head into step three and four and
again this is brought to you by
grow with video live this is actually a
snippet
of our grow with video live from last
year because we wanted to give you kind
of a behind the scenes of what you can
expect
at this year's grow with video live it's
coming up
so soon and i can't wait to see so many
content creators from around the world
join us for this virtual conference we
know that this year
was kind of a weird year so we decided
to keep it virtual so that you can
attend from anywhere
in the world you can get your tickets at
growethvideolive.com
and i'll tell you more about that at the
end of today's episode
well if you're ready let's get your
journal out and let's jump into
step three and four of this content
[Music]
number three create and post
a significant video every week
sean you're saying the same thing bro
then why aren't you doing it yet
oh called out huh come on why aren't you
being consistent yet
why aren't you committing to that weekly
upload
yet you'd be surprised and i want to for
those of you that are
for those who go that i've been grinding
man i have been doing that respect
but i am stunned by the amount of
comments i read
on think media or video influencers
where someone will be like
you talked about this strategy before so
because i read the comments
i click through i go to their channel
and i see that their channel
is 12 months old i see that they have
three uploads one is them like
with a phone recording their screen of
like a basketball game
the second is some random thing where
they talked about how they broke up with
their girlfriend
and the third is them with like a time
lapse
gopro on like their motorcycle and i'm
like
the frick are these videos like these
aren't these not
solving anybody's problem they don't
solve anybody's
ambition or what you're not even
listening and actually doing what we
tell you to
it doesn't work dawg i tried i uploaded
a better thought why are you worried
about your thumbnail yet you haven't
done the first couple pillars
you got to actually be ants like snowing
who you serve what's your topic
have you planted your flag remember
these moves are in order
if you don't do the right things in the
right order you're not going to get the
right results
and so there's something about
committing to listen
i wrote it this way for a reason you
want to create and post
a significant video every week what is
significant mean
let's define it i want you to post
one free high value video per week
solving your audience's problems and
helping them reach
their ambitions let me ask you a
question
if you're posting a video every week
that you actually know what people's
real problems are
and when they watch your video their
problems are solved
what do you think is going to happen
that's like real
that's how you build a bond with
somebody that's how you really build i
want to be famous and have everyone
follow you
why like what value do they get in
following you i just want to like have
like all these subscribers
why should they subscribe to your
channel but think about it who do you
follow you follow people that add value
to your life
that value could be entertainment or
that value could be education
but if you post a high value video
every week that actually solves a
problem every title of a youtube video
should make a promise to solve a problem
and then in the video if that problem is
solved
then what's gonna happen people be like
dude this chick is amazing
this guy is awesome like i came i was
super frustrated
couldn't my dishwasher was like leaking
water all over the ground
found the video now it's not leaking
water all over the ground
my man i want to share you with somebody
else you know
like i was i didn't really know how to
process this thing i was going through i
watched this video
they really kind of took me from
confusion to clarity
ask yourself where is the person that
you want to serve and help
and where do they want to go so each
week
the one video you create is not just
some random video about your random
thoughts
it's actually solving the audience's
problems but listen to this
it's helping them reach their ambitions
as well
so you ask yourself what are their
ambitions what is the ambitions that
they want to reach
for me right now i'm doing this crazy
thing called 75
heart all right now it's 75 days
where you work out twice a day it's
brutal during grow a video man
uh and you drink a gallon of water a day
you read 10 pages a day
um you uh no alcohol no
cheat meals at all commit to a diet 75
days no days off
worst idea i've ever committed to no
it's been amazing it transforms not just
your body but your mindset
and andy fursela it's a kind of a
movement he started love him love
love him love the movement love
everything about it so it's got me on
this whole thing like my whole life is a
different perspective now like i'm
thinking about i've been shopping for
like
you know i got some kettlebells and some
running clothes and some different
things
so i have ambitions one of my ambitions
is to be brad pitt fight club ripped
do you know the scene come on you know
it's actually funny because in the scene
he's got like a cigarette and a
budweiser but he's like cut up a little
bit
and he's you don't want to see
underneath here it's it is scrawny
shawn club ripped but the journey in the
mission is to get to brad pitt fight
club rip so guess what i've been finding
and i'm watching on youtube i'm clicking
on different videos i follow this
running channel i subscribe to them
they're talking about because i love
running which is not helping me get to
the ripped part
and so i'm watching them a little bit
i'm watching this other dude who's
talking about his daily routine he's
like just wake up and do 100 push-ups
it's a great way to start the day i'm
like oh it's easy for you to say bro
i'm going to get about 13 push-ups in
before my arms start to burn
i'm in process i'm working on it right
now and so
are you going to help people reach are
you helping people reach ambitions with
your
content so it's not just solving
problems this is kind of some advanced
marketing stuff
it's also thinking about what are
people's ambitions if you look at a
company like
apple they don't just solve a problem a
lot of companies
make technology products that suck
they solve a problem like a printer that
never works are you like me
printers are the worst right they run
out of ink you put the new black in
there
you print four pages and the black is
empty like
am i telling the truth and then you go
to like office deep especially with all
the virtual school that's happening
right now
you go in there you're like do you have
any black ink they're like no sorry
we're out of that ink
like it's just the worst and so there's
a lot of tech companies that just solve
a problem
apple doesn't just solve a problem man
they speak to your ambitions
man i want to be in the cool crowd i
want to wait outside in the snow so i
can get the latest iphone 12. come on
somebody
i want to i want to be a part of
something that's sleek i want to be a
dreamer
i want to be you know where are the
rebels where are the thought leaders
where are they
their their marketing is powerful
because it doesn't just solve problems
it also is an aspirational brand it is
it is something that they mark the
prices up on their stuff
there's a lot more cheaper smartphones
but people will go into debt
people who absolutely should not own a
smartphone an iphone
will go for the iphone because they've
built a powerful
brand that speaks to people's
ambitions how is your branding and your
channel not just solving problems but
helping people reach their ambitions
that's powerful so i want to encourage
you be consistent if you want to be
taken seriously
this number three now we're committed to
posting a video per week right
we're committed to uh posting a
significant video
and we just define what a significant
video was so if you want to be taken
seriously you got to be consistent
if you want to build trust you got to be
consistent
if you want to build momentum you need
to be consistent
if you want to be recognized and
remembered you need to be consistent
if you want to be considered dependable
you need to be consistent and don't you
want to be
because isn't somebody dependable on
youtube is somebody that you can
count on to upload consistent content
that has a consistent message and a
consistent brand at a consistent time
that solves a consistent problem that
you can consistently expect to deliver a
certain type of content to you
i think some of this is about us
deciding like we talked about at the
beginning
you're calling me out bro i gotta stop
dabbling and start dominating
and that means a commitment to
consistency this famous quote a river
cuts through rock not because of its
power but because of its persistence
i think about my journey and i think
about shooting
uploading my first video on youtube in
2010
and now 10 years later we're having
the most incredible virtual conference
that we've ever you know could have
imagined
so grateful that you're a part of this
and think media community that you get
to be a part of this session
and it's crazy to think of what's
happened in the last 10 years
but do you know what the last 10 years
has been it's been full of
a lot of obscurity a lot of no one
paying attention
no pats on the back haters trolls
dislikes self-doubt discouragement
depression not knowing if it's going to
work
wanting to give up that's what the last
10 years has been full of
incremental growth small steps
little little breakout videos and then
back to the grind
but that's what it takes because a river
cuts through the
rock not because of its power but
because of its persistence
there's something about defining your
positioning there's something about
understanding and defining your
audience's problems and desires
and then there's something about
committing to post at least
one significant post and some of you
need to stop posting so much
because you're posting like well i'm
posting like seven videos a week about
what
how about you make one significant post
make sure that you raise the quality
level
before you move into the quantity level
and make sure that that's
a consistent like man that's good hmm
think about like a restaurant
like you take your wife there you take
your partner there like once a week on a
date night
and you go there man the food's amazing
but what if you went like every day of
the week
and it was like good one night like kind
of mediocre the other and
some of those days it was just terrible
would you keep going no
it's very difficult to upload multiple
videos a week when you're just starting
i want to challenge you raise the
quality level
a significant post per week which brings
us to number four
and that is find the shortest path to
revenue find the shortest path
to revenue okay so we're going brick by
brick
number four we're on our journey to
building a real business and going full
time on youtube
what's the shortest path to revenue
what's the shortest path
not what are all of the paths for you
you want to answer the question
what's the shortest path to revenue in
my niche
so here's the questions what's the best
way for making money in my niche it's
different depending on the niche
like as a tech creator and a tech
youtuber affiliate marketing can be
it's a lot more because the products are
more expensive and there's a lot of
interest in them
you're maybe some other if you're a
booktuber not only is it going to be
potentially less because books aren't as
expensive but it's not even necessarily
the same level of volume or whatever so
you need a different
strategy a different approach so your
question is personalized
what's the best way for making money in
my niche and what's my
shortest path to revenue okay what is my
shortest path
personally and for my channel and for my
business
and then also how can i move my business
online how can i move
my business online again as we're even
thinking about this in 2020 we asked
that question in terms of monetization
because there's been so much disruption
no matter who you are you've got to
figure out how to be online i know we're
talking about youtube
but you got to figure out how to create
multiple streams of income if you've got
a brick and mortar business
or an in-person business and figure out
how to also do virtual live streaming in
youtube
these are good monetization questions
now as we land the plane i
will never forget october 2015 on this
journey of these first four steps right
and in october 2015 um that was a big
transition
month for me at the time i was
freelancing full-time
and i had been on staff at a church and
building on my youtube channels on the
side
i had worked with other clients during
this season of my life i had three main
clients
and one was paying me 2 000 a month
another was paying me 2 000 a month and
the third was paying me one thousand a
month
about five thousand dollars a month
making around 300
500 a month of online income and things
were going great but october 2015 hur
a hit and that first week i'll never
forget get a phone call
hey sean yeah what up man we're hiring a
full-time person we gotta let you go
uh and uh we just don't need you for
freelance anymore
okay cool kind of a bummer lost one of
the 2k clients but i was like well i'll
just get another one not a big deal
you know uh we'll see it should be fine
second week
of october 2015. bring you guessed it
hey sean uh here's the deal man we're
making some changes
uh we we don't need you anymore we gotta
let you go
second two thousand dollar client just
lost four thousand dollars in two weeks
maybe you can relate
because this was a personal recession
for me and our family
so now i'm kind of stressed i don't want
to tell my wife sonia
because i'm like okay i can figure this
out i could i'm gonna get something
together i'm gonna call some people i'm
gonna figure this out
third week october 2015.
now i'm like terrified with the phone
calls you know i get a vibrates in my
pocket you get like anxiety
cortisol and stress levels i'm like okay
i just fit you know the way 2020 is
going it's probably just going to be
more bad news
sure enough sean got to let you go man
we don't need you anymore we lost 80
to 90 of our income in three weeks in
october 2015.
like i'm losing my mind i i'm i'm
freaked out
it's sick that youtube was something i
was building up
and i was doing the stuff that i do now
for other people
but i wasn't even necessarily able to
connect to to go all in on youtube
because i was doing so much client work
but now i'm freaking out because i'm
like how are we gonna pay our bills
we're months away from
zero in our bank account and it was at
that time
this is actually the the era this we
were living in irvine california
i was walking marking my dogs there at
the apartment complex we were living in
and um and this was my office in our
apartment
uh in irvine and so i'm freaked out i
don't know what to do
and so i call a friend of mine business
guy
uh you know friend that was a part of
our church mentor his name's david and i
was like hey david i'm freaking out i'm
losing my mind i don't know
we our money in our account there's not
much there i just lost all my clients
and he goes you know sean i'm not
worried
at which point i get super offended i'm
like you're not worried
i know you're not worried david like
you're independently wealthy that's cool
you're not
you don't worry about anything bro like
you've like sold companies and stuff
i'm calling you because i'm worried
david like
listen and he's like no i'm not worried
and ultimately i was glad he said that
because he was like because this is your
time to go all in
this is your time to i was like do i get
other freelance clients he's like no
with where you're at right now
you got to go all in at some point
entrepreneurs have to jump off the cliff
it sounds like god just kicked you off
the cliff and now it's time to fly
and maybe it works maybe it doesn't but
i think that's the move to make is to go
all in with video and do what you know
to do
and start hustling when it comes to
video and here was this was that time
when that happened
think media was at 16 000 subscribers
friday october 2nd uh 2015.
crazy we're at 1.3 million just five
years later right
uh at the time benji uh my friend from
the small town we grew up in together
in the seattle area we we had started
video influencers that 8
573 subscribers i want to encourage you
again
don't despise small beginnings and don't
despise
uh starting small because all big things
all great things start
small and check out this video this is
what i started to do
uh back when all of that was happening
what is the best and cheapest lighting
for your youtube videos that's super
easy to use and set up
we're going to talk about that in this
video
hey what's up sean here talking about my
favorite
cheap lighting for youtube videos that
looks incredible
so here's the thing man if if you notice
some things anybody who's like been
around think media for a while let me
know in the chat or the comments man
shout me out
how long have you been a part of the
think fam let me know
but like when i see that video i just
see the camera's not as nice
we're in our apartment that was my wife
sonia in the background
and dude i just feel like i'm just
saying the same thing but
it's been a very powerful thing because
i defined my positioning and i'm going
to help you find cheap lighting guess
what
there's new lights today like the gvm
lights we've been using right there's
new cameras every year there's new
cameras
like every year but i i claimed and
mastered my topic
right i keep asked thinking about man
what questions
is our community asking and i keep
answering
community questions and today now we got
omar
crushing you to think media right now we
got nolan making crazy videos and we're
growing as a team
and now we're a community of creators
years later but it started by number
three
creating a significant post per week and
i just started to make videos
and here's what happened this is even
back during that journey
this is some early amazon revenue that
you could see here there's actually 2014
on the journey up when i was shooting
videos like that
374 dollars a month christmas by the way
which is coming up depending on when
you're watching this
901 dollars a month you want a tip get
ready now for holiday shopping
it's crazy every year q4 is when most
businesses grow
even in the midst of everything that's
going it's going to blow up no matter
what black friday cyber monday i don't
care what niche
you're in start making your game plan
right now one of the things i even knew
back then
901 dollars was actually at that time
oh that's crazy extra money that was the
side money right then when i was
freelancing full-time
right but i just think big things
great things start small a couple
hundred hundred dollars extra a month is
very significant
but recently it's crazy to look back
cnbc
i don't know if you saw this did like a
mini documentary about me and think
media
and we nearly did 40 000 in just one
month
on just the amazon associates program my
friends
that has now become one piece of our
overall media business
that has 10 different income streams
that are significant each in their own
right
listen that was not overnight that was
brick by brick
piece by piece and here's the key you
got to find the shortest path to revenue
let me know if you know the answer that
question and you need to focus on your
shortest path there's a lot of paths
but you got to focus on your shortest
path if you know it tell me in the
comments
what path are you focusing on for
revenue for me i'm not saying this is
the best for you but for a lot of you it
probably is
in the comments for me it was affiliate
marketing and you saw the journey it was
you know 300 300 900
and eventually that was the thing it was
youtube
kind of youtube ads but affiliate
marketing because of the niche tech
over the next couple days of growth
video live we're going to help you get
clarity on what your best path for not
just
revenue but for growth really dialing in
your positioning helping you discover
your target audience
to answer their problems and step by
step we're going to go
through the this process and this
framework but i want to encourage you
i talked about a lot in this session and
tell me in the comments tell me in the
live chat
what has been your biggest aha moment
what has been your
takeaway for what you need to do next
and i want to encourage you
if you're still on the fence you gotta
just start
you need to start before you're ready
you know you don't have to be great to
start
but you have to start to be great
you gotta punch fear in the face you
gotta punch perfectionism in the face
and you have to press record and start
making videos
on a little webcam like that or five
years earlier when i was
you know just sitting at that desk and
just start messy and start posting
videos because we are living
through one of the greatest revolutions
in human history because of the internet
because of social media because of
online video and it is absolutely not
too late
people are going to keep saying that and
cynical people are going to keep
complaining
but never let somebody that has given up
on their dreams
talk you out of yours stop scrolling and
start posting
stop looking at what everybody else is
doing and stop sitting on the sidelines
and get in the game
stop worrying about fear of missing out
stop comparing yourself to everybody
else and focus on your craft
your videos put your blinders on work
these steps
and you can build your influence faster
than you would
ever believe if you stay focused and
work a system
that really works well that wraps up
step one through four
from growth video live last year and i'm
excited for
what's to come this year but before we
get there my question to you is
what action do you need to take next
after listening to
both last week's episode and this week's
episode
what is your shortest path to income who
do you want to impact on your youtube
channel and what is the clarity
that you need to move you forward one of
the pieces i can let you know
from my own journey on youtube because
of my
schedule and just the amount of things i
have on my plate
i always keep this acronym at the
forefront
k-i-s-s the kiss acronym keep it simple
and short now i know other people use
that acronym for other things but that's
what i think about when i'm making
youtube channels
keep it simple and short what's my
shortest path to revenue
how can i make this video not 20 minutes
but
10 minutes thinking about just always
keeping it simple
helps me be able to create content on a
more consistent basis
so what's the action step that you need
to take to move your youtube channel
forward i hope that one of the action
steps you need to take
is attending our conference grow with
video live now
if you've never attended a virtual
conference before
i want to let you know a couple things
you can expect one you can expect myself
and sean cannell
and so many of our think media team to
be delivering
top-notch actionable steps that you
could be taking to grow your youtube
channel
this year we've really taken a large
amount of survey and advice from
you the think community on what you are
looking for in a conference and we've
compiled
all of that information to put together
this year's
conference we're going to be
interviewing people everyday normal
creators just like you who went from
zero to over a hundred thousand
and we're going to be breaking down that
journey of not only how did they stay
consistent
in their regular everyday lives but how
did they
get their videos to get views and go
viral and
how do they make money on their youtube
channels we're going to be breaking down
in short ted talk like sessions to help
give you that punchy
actionable steps that you can take away
and start applying on your youtube
channel we have so many surprises in
store
like our fun games that we play amazing
giveaways like
full youtube studios cameras gear
software
so many great things and not only that
but we've set aside so much networking
time for you
we heard from the think community that
one of the things that you want
is to be able to meet people who are
doing what you're doing
and so at this year's growth video live
we've set aside time for you to meet
people who
are in your space or people who are just
on
the platform making content at a certain
stage
just like you i cannot wait for you to
meet content creators
from all over the world and to be able
to hang out with the think media team to
get your questions answered
so much is happening at this two-day
event that you don't want to miss it
go to growethvideolive.com to see our
affordable tickets that we have for sale
right now now if you've been a member of
this
think community you know that my
favorite part is getting to read
your comments and today's comment comes
from
r roberts our robert says clear and
actionable teaching
the think media team always gives clear
teaching that you can quickly begin
applying
i'm just starting my journey on youtube
and the think marketing podcast
now the think media podcast has already
shifted
how i think about my content and my
brand well r roberts thank you so much
for being a part of this community
for leaving that review over on apple
and i want to encourage you to leave a
review if you haven't
already my favorite thing is to get to
see what the think community is up to
and to see all of these wonderful
reviews that you've left this helps
other content creators know
that this is the place for them thank
you so much for being a part of this
community
for taking us along on your youtube
journey and
for being a part of just this movement
of content creators around the world
we'll see you in the next episode bye
not growing on youtube learn the newest
strategies for getting views and the
best proven ways to make money
at grow with video live a two-day
virtual conference
and you can get your tickets today at
growwithvideolive.com